hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control sc.l
2-3.13.7 prevent remote devices from
simultaneously establishing non-remote
connections with organizational systems
and communicating via some other
connection to resources and external
networks I.E split tunneling and the
longest run-on sentence ever in
compliance history
[Music]
all right
so hey if you're a defense contractor is
feeling overwhelmed tired and alone
trying to understand all of this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 10171 compliance stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news for you you
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it baby all right you gotta love the
folks who wrote this because they are
bringing in Old School basic best
practices and mixing it up a little bit
for us in these control families this
control is all about lowering the
footprint and number of vectors of
attack here's how the attack Works your
home computer gets compromised by an
attacker with a remote connection into
your PC maybe because your grandma
thought that that awesome tech support
was something she needed
we've been there
it's just a minute it's okay
We All Fall for attack
you then spin up a VPN connection to the
end of the corporate Network and
theoretically they have access except
that the compromise is to your home
computer that just connected your
corporate Network and it relies on that
base internet connection to stay
connected when you use the VPN tunnel to
talk to your corporate Network
boom hackers get in with very little
friction and life gets ugly for you baby
we don't want that to happen now if when
you connect to your corporate VPN it
does not allow those two connections to
communicate simultaneously and only
allows internet originating through the
VPN tunnel when it's connected then the
attacker gets cut off because the
outside base internet connection is not
allowed in out traffic anymore that all
has to go through the singular VPN
connection and nobody on the outside can
really enter that
this is why split tunneling is so
dangerous and if you're trying to be
compliant it's just simply not allowed
now let's see what the assessors are
looking for on this one
really only looking for one thing
determine if remote devices are
prevented from simultaneously
establishing non-remote connections with
the system and communicating via some
other connection to resources and
external networks I.E split tunneling
I.E they just pretty much wrote the
control again so how do we do that uh
we're gonna we're gonna say hey split
tunneling is turned off for VPN access
right that's we're going to write in the
plan and realistically uh we're just
gonna have to show this uh configuration
to an assessor right you're gonna have
to prove to them that that's what what
the reality is
now uh at on call we work with defense
contractors just like you who have had
this dfars nist itar and cmmc compliance
stuff dropped in their laps like a
seagull on a sunny day and we teach you
how to level up and be a proper on-call
compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps great areas and getting
this solved almost showing you how to
leverage compliance is your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that's what
becoming an on-call compliance hero can
do for you if you're looking for more
help getting compliant our compliance
experts are always on call for you visit
cmmcc complianceecrets.com or check out
the bio below for links to get help
right now if you love the content we're
putting out here for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash the Subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliance starts
roll it out until next compliance tip my
friends stay safe and secure out there
hit us in the comments below to let us
know what you'd like to know more about
when it comes to information security
and compliance and we'll see you on the
next one
[Music]
foreign